good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday i hope
no excuse excuse me excuse me i think
the stress brothers are here for nothing
i'm so sorry because we did you know the
monday episode sunday i'm also clamped
i'm all out of sorts happy wednesday
everyone hope everyone's having an
amazing hump day
don't forget to hump someone you love
even if it's a streist brother
especially if it's a strike brother
especially you guys i hope we're coming
through crystal clear today yes there
was an audio snafu yesterday but you
know what
it's not a mistake if you learn
something a hundred percent
plenty let's talk about it and now we
have a checklist we were early yesterday
we were like we had plans we're like
we're gonna get in and so early we
finished we felt good amerigo busboochie
grabbed my computer i get the audio off
of our system in a little micro card sd
thank you
memory card and i plug it into my
computer and it's like sounding a little
weird because i'm not there and i'm like
i probably wouldn't have even noticed if
it was you but thank god it was me
because i noticed chills and i'm like
wait mine's like oh jackie being low
again she's so shy she's so quiet who
cares but then i was like me
so i look down at our system and i see
i'm mic number two you're my number one
i see mic number two
wasn't on
so i audibly gasp
and i look at it and jackie you say what
and you look at what i'm looking at and
then you go
and that's really the end of the story
so here's the question were you silent
or were you silenced
i definitely wasn't silent no never you
the thing is for me you don't even have
to ask that question because i'm never
silent if i'm silent it's because i've
been silenced
does that make sense yeah
so we did what we could to salvage the
um audio
from yesterday it was fine of course you
know everyone was upset but again i'm so
flattered by like the influx of right
you kind of like comments when we have
issues because it just shows you like
how important people
need you and how many people are
listening because when things are good
they're gonna hear from less people
people are enjoying no news is good news
but if you want news put out bad news
100
and boy did we get bad news yesterday
and of course like you know
i hate when that happens like for a
million reasons trust us no one is more
frustrated than us and if we could
record an entire other episode again we
would but like it would be fraudulent
like we'd be making the same america
joshua
how did we even work amerigo into the
conversation i don't know he wouldn't
have made it into take two yeah so like
this is just
we've done it before where we've
recorded like 20 minutes and we realized
someone's microphone wasn't on so we
start over but you really just can't
re-record
the same whole episode like it's just if
we didn't have a backup audio and the
first audio was unusable then we would
have had to re-record yeah but i think
putting out like the
take to watered-down version would have
been worse than the take one
murky audio no it's just like
inauthentic and we're extremely
authentic like it's crazy you smell that
it's our authenticity
so
it is what it is we have a checklist now
like jackie said it's not a mistake if
you learned something and what we
learned is like we need a routine a
checklist of everything we need to make
sure we do when we're recording together
and when we're recording separately so
that video is taken care of so that
audio is taken care of and now we have
two checklists they're pinned up on the
wall they're quite beautiful um and we
went through it today and so let's hope
let's pray let's say you know what all
together everyone close your eyes let's
just all collectively
pray
and hope and dream and wish
that the audio on today's episode is
premium and crisp that the video was so
sharp you could see this pimple on my
forehead
that the smell-o-vision is so good you
could smell my breath
amen smell theo's infected food yeah it
doesn't smell does it no but it looks
like it does you know for sure but they
said like his infection just kind of
tinted the fur around his
um foot and like it'll just grow out
it's not gonna go away it's just like
the fur is
it's useless we gotta get rid of it yeah
it's very pleny it's very plenty
understood well
we're so glad to be here today and if
you're looking for some more crystal
clear audio we dropped a patreon episode
yesterday doing what is always
everyone's favorite thing that we do on
patreon we do it every few months
uh we did general q a where you can ask
us any question in the facebook group
and we'll answer most of them we
actually had some really good combos
yesterday yes and we got really good
like unique interesting questions
and i enjoyed it except for the part
where you probably like said
unintentionally like the meanest thing
you ever could have said to me and like
really um
kind of dug in on my insecurities i
didn't know i was doing any of those
things i thought i was giving you a
compliment as you know some of the worst
insults always are 100 because i would
rather someone say something mean like
knowing that they were trying to be mean
it's like oh you were just trying to
hurt my feelings
as opposed to like that's your truth
right and it's my
burden and so if you want to know what
we're talking about unfortunately we
can't tell you you just have to hear it
for yourself at patreon.com morning
toast yeah um so it's been a really
[ __ ] treacherous day for me because
we had such a great evening you and i
and zach all the boys on the couch well
harry was asleep we stayed up till late
like 11 30. for me yeah and we watched
tim dillon's new comedy special we were
cackling it's always very scary to watch
someone who you like on the internet
in real life on like stand up because
you never know how it's going to
translate it was wild honestly it's i've
said this before on the podcast but like
the way that i like spend nights
thinking about like maybe something that
could be misconstrued on the podcast
versus what tim dillon was saying in his
comedy special on a on a real streaming
service on netflix i'm like what am i
worried about he used three slurs i was
like shook yeah so also not to make
everything not to make team dylan
special about me but i was very relieved
uh it was so good it was really so funny
i never seen this comedy before because
when he played in new york i was pretty
pregnant so i couldn't go and i was so
bummed and then when i saw he was
recording a special i was like wherever
it is i'm going to watch it if it's on
his patreon yeah i'll get the wrong
patreon
membership like whatever it is but it's
on netflix and it's called a real tim
dylan a real hero and there were like
some we were bold coal miner the the
coal miner moment i haven't laughed that
hard in a very long time and the little
caesars moment for me was really special
it was really good i mean if you're not
into like even remotely offensive comedy
you're not gonna like it but it was
[ __ ] funny like really funny really
[ __ ] funny and it was the perfect
length i think and i think for youtube
48 minutes i think i thought it was the
perfect length and i was just feeling
good about the night you know you and i
made popcorn we did we put them in
little containers that said popcorn you
were so cute and like you know kind of
like giving blogger like but that's what
happens when you move to the suburbs
like you because of space for crap you
become like a
a mommy blogger suburban mom and that is
like chachi's that's what's happened to
me except i've had those popcorn things
since like three apartments ago but now
i can finally use them because i can see
where they are hundred percent and it
was just a gorgeous evening yeah go to
bed 11 30 tick tock till 12.
fall asleep wake up i gotta pee whatever
time it is oh i look over it's two
o'clock go pee get back in bed
and i'm
awake like for the day
like there's no way i'm flipping and
flipping at 3 30 i did eventually get on
my phone and like every 30 minutes i
would like watch go to try and sleep
watch go inside
by about five o'clock i had given in to
the fact that i was awake for the day
and honestly i just couldn't get over it
like it's so stupid but then my fate
changed because i was on tick tock and i
saw this clip from an interview and i
like didn't even know what the interview
was about or who this this person was
but the girl looked vaguely familiar did
i tell you this this morning yet no i
watched your story but i have no idea
who you're talking about okay i'm about
to blow your mind can't wait so
her name was jordan turpin and they were
just telling this story like this crazy
story and i'm like you know let me go
find this full diane sawyer because they
were like on tick tock watch five
minutes part one and then i'd go watch a
million other videos like let me just
find the whole thing on youtube
it was this hour-long diane sawyer
interview sitting down with jordan and
jennifer turpin
and if you're like into like if you
follow
like it's not true crime but like if you
just follow like crazy [ __ ] that happens
it's like a famous story and it's
somewhat recent i had never heard of it
but this girl jackie she looked so
familiar
so the story is crazy jordan is the
younger sister of the two they're
sisters they're sisters okay oh no
they're not married they're sisters
they're one of 12
13 siblings
and they lived in a house
like condemned like
feces hoarders
disgust in like two or three bedrooms
filled with bunk beds with all the kids
ranging from like 10 to 30.
all these kids who have literally never
left their house and when they do it's
like four times in their lifetime where
their parents like literally force them
to act normal
they were living in filth they never
bathed they were never went to school
they
they had such a limited vocabulary their
parents chain them up
beat them abuse them like the worst
[ __ ] thing you can think of
and after a while jordan
gets access to a cell phone
and eventually she's the one who climbs
out of a window in the middle of the
night because they the parents tell them
we're moving to oklahoma tomorrow
jordan's like i'm not we're never none
of us are going to survive they're so
malnourished they're not going to
survive a trip to oklahoma jordan's like
tonight's the night she jumps out of a
window with the cell phone
runs down the block and calls a cop and
of course they have all the uh 911
operator uh
recordings and you hear her and it
sounds like a teenage runaway she's like
i ran away from home she doesn't know
like she never like she watched a little
tv and i'm gonna get into that in a
minute because that's the part i think
you find interesting
she couldn't even she had such limited
vocabulary
so she has to wait 14 minutes
for the cops they're living in
california they did live in texas for a
little while the parents left them for
three years in a trailer and would
literally drop off food for them like
not even enough groceries they were
rationing it and they would make the
older siblings put the younger siblings
in cages and the older sibling jennifer
was like that was the worst part because
if i didn't do it like they would kill
me like they were like they would
literally come where the parents going
when they would come on the thing doing
whatever they want party going to vegas
and i feel sick no totally but they were
also like really religious like
episcopalian it was so confusing okay
jordan runs out she gets to the corner
she's on with the lady the lady's like
14 minutes i'm like oh my god 14 minutes
like okay
the cop pulls up at me the body cam
footage and they actually have the cop
on the dianne sawyer thing and then it
gets reunited with the girl i was really
cute
but he's like you know
i took this call because it was the end
of my shift and teenage runaways are
always like you just got to bring the
kid back to the parents in a great it's
a great way to end your shift it's not
like a
high stress situation and he's like
that's what i'm thinking this whole time
and she sounded kind of weird they have
like accents they've literally never
been a part of civilization
and she doesn't know like so many of the
words he was like are you on medication
she's like what's that
he's like pills she's like no sometimes
we get robitussin like if we have a
cough
and then and then he was like um
are you injured she's like what's that
he's like are you hurt she's like not
right now no um and thank god he like he
was suspicious because he was weird
thank god this random iphone she managed
to get
she snapped a couple pics before she
left like in case anyone needed proof
because one of these other sisters one
time saw an episode of cops and they
needed proof that's how they knew what
proof was like that's how they were
learning things so crazy she had a
picture two of her younger sisters and
that's why they really needed to get out
two of the younger sisters had been in
chains for weeks only let out to go to
the bathroom
even sometimes not even let out to go to
the bathroom thank god you just took
this picture this cop saw the picture of
these two malnourished kids locked up in
chains in this disgusting
filthy filthy [ __ ] house and then he
was like oh my god so the whole ordeal
from the time that she leaves to the
time that the cops get there it's about
two hours she stays
with
the police officer but she keeps saying
she's like if my parents figure out that
i left like
we're [ __ ]
two hours later they go in for a
wellness check even though nobody called
in on a wellness check like they have
enough proof
these two [ __ ] forlorn disgusting
satanic [ __ ] walk out of the house and
are like what's going on
and they're like we got a well in the
shack uh you have kids in here and
they're like yeah
you gotta let us in
it's okay so they go in and it's
disgusting but she says to them you know
we're moving tomorrow so just don't mind
the filth and i guess like being
disgusting isn't a crime it is an unsafe
environment for children but so far they
haven't seen the chains the chains is
what they're looking for but i guess
when the parents were being weird
outside they were telling the other kids
get rid of the chains get rid of the
chains get rid of the chains so they go
into the two bedrooms and there's really
skinny kids in disgusting conditions but
again
not like that thing they needed they
needed the chains
so they're talking to the dad they're
talking to the dad
then this cop realizes he's standing in
front of a bunch of moving boxes the
moving boxes are covering another door
in the door
is another room for the other kids
and there's one kid locked up in chains
and then once it's all out there
another one of the kids is like yeah all
the chains are in the closet they just
made us throw them in there and that was
like the thing they needed they were
they pled guilty within four days
whatever the story gets even crazier
okay
i'm sorry if you guys know the story and
you're familiar with it but i got a lot
of messages any of this okay sweetie
gets crazier when she starts explaining
like the context of how she knew things
like what gave her jordan is the one who
ran and jennifer was like her accomplice
and jennifer was the older one like
jennifer went to school for three years
no sorry until the third grade because
she's an older kid but then they stopped
sending their kids to school and had a
bunch of other kids so she had like a
small context of how life was not
supposed to be like this but some of the
kids were born into it but she knew she
knew it was bad
so jennifer got this phone
and she loves to sing and she was like
making videos of her singing in the
bathroom at night
and she would post them on like this
like social media account that she made
and someone was messaging her and was
like why are you only ever singing in
the bathroom and at night well she's
like oh that's how my life is blah blah
and this guy random guy on the internet
was like that's not normal she didn't
know that because she'd been like that
her whole life she's like wait what
so then what really changed it all is
when she found justin bieber and
honestly when she was talking about
justin bieber i could cry and of course
i googled of course she's like since met
justin justin brought her to concert
because apparently the story galvanized
the nation i never heard of it
so she's when was this so she got out in
2018 and the interview
they all mostly all of the kids are
anonymous except for the two sisters who
finally showed their faces in 2022. this
interview is like very new
maybe it's 2016 2020 it was four years
later
so
she's like i used to watch these justin
bieber music videos and i couldn't
believe like there are it's just you
know those young music videos it's like
they're at a bowling alley and they're
having so much fun she's like
is that like a
possibility like i want that life like
look like they're having so much fun and
so it was like these little seeds of
things that she used to see high school
musical that would like when her parents
were out they had a tv but of course the
kids weren't allowed to watch it but the
parents would leave for like long
amounts of time and they were able to
like get some context it's like what the
[ __ ] is going on in the world
and they never left because they were
like our parents like will actually like
murder us like and jordan knew she's
like i if i get caught like i'm dead but
at least i know i tried it was so
[ __ ] sad and so all of the things
that
led her to the place where she was able
to like come to the realization and then
find the courage to leave was from like
pop culture in a way because that was
really the only things they had access
to but also really [ __ ] up like
manipulative [ __ ] like they were
bankrupt of course because nobody was
working they were just beating their
kids and literally they used to go drive
themselves into debt going to target or
walmart and getting tons of brand new
kids toys for the mom
they were never open no one was allowed
to use them so the police walk in
they're like oh all these kids toys it
looks like santa's you know workshop no
they were never allowed to touch them
so [ __ ] weird
wait it gets so much worse okay so the
kids range when they when they get
saved from about 10 to 30
that means the kids who are under 18
have to re-enter the foster care system
and why can't their older siblings adopt
them because their older siblings are
under a guardianship from the
uh government because they they're not
really like
fully formed adults or they're stunted
they would say there was 12 year olds in
there who had the arms of four month
olds infants like that's how crazy
malnourished they were
so wait it gets even more [ __ ] up so
the kids who went to foster care it they
abc news was killing it like literally
investigative calling everyone because
the town is covering it up
council member they're chasing council
members through the lobby i'm like yeah
get them everyone's covering it up the
kids are in the foster care system there
are two kids at least that we know of
who were in homes who were then rated
for abuse so they went from one hell to
another hell can you believe that
then the older kids you know it was a
story that galvanized the nation
they raised just regular people go fund
me things like that 600 grand for them
it was put in a trust by the government
this got one of the the older the oldest
one 30. he's like i just wanted a bike
like i have a job like i want to get
around no i couldn't get a bike like
they have no access to their own money
they're living in squalor the person
who's like the trustee of the account of
course abc news got their name vanessa
hunting them down oh she no longer works
for the government like so [ __ ] shady
nothing has changed the kids are living
like
like nothing well obviously the kids in
foster care are just going to a
different sort of hell and the ones who
are older have no help this like task
force was put together to help them and
the money and like guide them through
life be like they were supposed to help
them like use public transit he would
call vanessa how do i figure it out
crazy like he got so [ __ ] up
afterwards even more
but the thing that really struck me was
jennifer the older one
who was in it the longest and like it
was just and she knew that it wasn't
supposed to be that way because she
lived
even when she was in school she was
never getting showered like they were
not taking care of her but she got to go
to school
she said diane sorry was like what do
you guys want to do now and here's what
was crazy jordan the one who jumped out
the window was like i love making tick
tocks i'm like
that's how i know her because for a
while this blonde girl kept coming up on
my tick tocks
and i was like
reading the comments because she was so
frail
and everyone in the comments is like you
look so good i'm so happy for you
and i'm like wait what because she was
literally like
they said she had the legs of like a six
year old so i was like i remember being
so confused and not looking into it
further and then they put up some of her
tic tacs i'm like oh my god i've seen
her dancing then i had to go follow her
this morning and then the older girl and
it's really interesting how the whole
time
well the two girls i don't know about
all the other kids the two girls were
like so
um like strong in their faith like they
kept talking about god even though their
parents were like crazy [ __ ] who like
had so many kids for god and like was
doing all this for god like
they still remained really steadfast in
their faith which i thought was really
interesting and then the older girl
diane was like what do you want to do
she's like i want to be a christian pop
star and dan was like who do you love
like she was like i love kelly clarkson
wait and she was like what's your
favorite color i'm like literally gonna
cry she was like what's your favorite
kylie clarkson song and she was like
broken and beautiful that new one she
was like that's true from troll she was
like that's me i'm broken but it's
beautiful
it was uh i feel like i was meant to
wake up so early so i could watch
i'm
i can't believe i didn't know about this
so i'm sorry if you knew that already i
spent literally 16 minutes
jackie it was a craziest i need to watch
more documentaries like i need to know
more and like going to the sentencing
the two older kids spoke and then some
of the kids wrote letters that the older
kids spoke and like some of them were
like forgiving i'm like okay you could
never be me forgiving like we see you
some other kids were like [ __ ] you like
this is my life now and the two parents
got 25 to life right they're in separate
prisons um the dad was like oh i have a
statement but my lawyer has to read it
like shut up okay that's not about you
and then the mom read a statement and
she's like i'm sorry that i hurt my kids
like i just
i'm not buying it you know sorry's not
going to cut it sorry and that's really
what they said they were like you know
we watched her her crying on with the
speech and you know we believed her
she's our mom
and
they were like we don't even like to
call her mom but we will for the sake of
this interview but they used to make us
call them mother and father but like i
call her tracy or whatever the [ __ ] her
name was um they were like we watched
this apology like believed her but then
it's like we remembered she's so [ __ ]
manipulative like you have to remember
that they're like we have no interest in
like ever communicating with her for now
like maybe that'll change but like for
now it's gonna be a no
it was the craziest journey i went on
this morning um that makes me so sick
jackie was [ __ ] sick especially the
part where like it's still
not going for them
and the kids in the foster care the
foster care system
it's and that's what the person on the
expert was saying like this is a system
that was literally created for the sole
purpose of helping people helping kids
helping kids and it's literally the most
twisted it's the most like [ __ ] up and
so i loved that abc was like dragging
everyone like the companies the people
they're calling out employees by name
i'm like yeah vanessa they were just
honestly they were doing great reporting
diane sawyer she kills it but it's crazy
how like one everyone
in general in theory like we're here we
need to help the children right these
kids are in trouble there's a task force
dedicated to helping these kids the
whole world is paying attention and it's
still they're not helping the kids no
it's so disgusting the government is
literal trash and also like the girl who
went to school until third grade like
showing up not showered like the
teachers are supposed to okay so that's
what they said they said
now they all went back to like her
school records was there any reporting
of
apparently if the two telltale signs of
abuse are like if a kid shows up really
thin and like malnourished looking and
um unwashed like unveiled dirty clothes
those are the two telltale signs and
according to a classmate of her like
apparently this guy when this whole
story came out he's a doctor now
his facebook post went viral because he
was like i remember jennifer
because she was the kid nobody wanted to
talk to they were in the second grade so
like the kids obviously the kids didn't
right
no better views he said we remember like
the smelly kid and he's like the guilt i
feel for not like acknowledging or
reporting even though it's not on the
kids it's on the adults and it's a
failure on everyone at that school and
oh by the way there were so many things
so they were homeschooled because it's
not legal to just pull your kids out of
school there's a record they set up oh
the principal is the dad whatever they
set up this fraudulent homeschooling
they never homeschool the kids and
you're supposed to have monthly weekly
when you're i don't know the whole thing
but like when you're part of the
american homeschooling system there are
weekly check-ins that you have to
provide you have to provide curriculum
no one was ever checking in there was
like a million ways when like there was
a million ways that they could have
been like a tipped off to what was going
on never it took the kid with a girl
risking her life jumping out of the
window
to save her and her siblings and it was
just the way they were talking about the
siblings oh it was just terrible it was
so so sad that's so sad you know what it
also makes me sad to think about not to
make it worse but like i think a lot of
situations teachers do recognize signs
of abuse and that's how a lot of kids
are are helped and saved um but also
think about how many kids
during covet and didn't go to school and
i know absolutely like didn't have food
at home one a lot of kids like when they
go to school like they're getting a
lunch they're getting like a meal uh-huh
and that's so important for them they're
also getting like all these things if
they socialize
yeah and there's so many degrees of a
bad home life and there's obviously that
extreme but there's also you know lesser
forms and like all those kids stayed
home for over a year i know and all
those signs of abuse
went unseen but you know what else it's
like gabriel fernandez his teachers saw
bruises and sensed cps and it made his
home situation worse
so it's
like there's really no
like saving kids in that situation
because
only you know maybe one out of ten times
does it actually work and then wait no
the people they get out of the abusive
home and into a foster care home that's
decent
at best at best right yeah and i'm sure
there's some lovely foster care this is
not a general it's an exception yeah
it's the exception yeah no even if
you're able to get the teachers see it
cps does their job they take the kid
where do they put them right because
with the gabriel fernandez situation it
was a huge failure on cps
it's so much so i think like gabriel
fernandez even had a file i think the
fbi even looked into it because it was
so obvious like they had one of the
nurses in the documentary being like i
never saw anything like that in my life
it was just i'm sorry to like be so dark
but it was just really eye-opening and
really
horrible
but like now like i love following her
on tech talks do they get their money
yet because of diane sawyer i don't know
but like we're gonna need to follow up
we're gonna need another gofundme yeah
totally directly or let's all just like
follow them on tick tock like that's a
way of supporting people like brand
deals things like that like jennifer
also has a tick tock the other ones um
the oldest one who didn't want to show
his face but sent like a little video of
himself from the back his name is jordan
we don't know any other kids names
because they've been protected obviously
they've chosen not to participate which
is totally understandable so i think in
our own ways like we can help
i followed her like everyone should
follow her
yeah so that's what i do
follow her that's a good worthy cause
that's what i did this morning um i feel
like it's i've been up what time is it
almost 10 hours i don't know like where
this road takes me i've never slept two
hours before i think it takes you to a
nap
a nap and then we have our meet and
greet right so like i have to be on
maybe i'll like nap in the car on the
way to the meet and greet i think that's
like why don't you nap after this
i don't know i just like i'm here i want
to spend time with kaler i want to spend
time with you like i want to go outside
in the pool like you don't want to waste
hours damn daylight i know that's how
you're supposed to sleep at night when
nothing's happening yeah no i tried that
it just it wasn't working for me i'm
sorry
so that's what i did how was your uh
morning obviously different than mine
obviously different than yours but it's
been actually a nice morning because
we're moving like a little slowly and
that is very helpful for me
so it was going really well until you
shared that story yeah i'm so sorry
i don't know how to pivot well i really
don't know i know i'm like kind of like
what [ __ ] and a lot of times you share a
sad story but it's been a few years and
here's where they are now no i know and
you didn't give us that no but that is
worse and worse the two girls who we
know seem to be doing really great like
they both are so beautiful
i think that the way that they were
raised in terms of like health will
impact their health forever like i don't
think they can really like realistically
change that the way that they look like
they're both super super thin
um
but the thing is it's like we don't know
about the other kids so like that's
where the darkness lies
yeah
so
i'm so sorry to have done that to
everyone um
but it's something that needs to be
spoken about like [ __ ] that city
councilwoman and the one that spoke to
them retelling of it was very good if
you ever wanted to do like a podcast
about
crazy true stories i think you had a
future i feel like
this is a general statement on the true
crime genre and this is not saying that
those people are bad or that people
listen or bad there doesn't feel
something like inherently weird about
talking about like a very gruesome
murder or a tragedy in a small town
brought to you by like like it's the
monetization and like the the cult
following vibe of true crime podcast
does like give me a little bit of the
heebie-jeebies
i hear that and i don't disagree with
you i can't really speak to it because
i've never listened to an episode by the
way it's important to share that i
haven't either in every single episode
there you know they come at it from like
an emotional point of view they're
affecting change they're solving crimes
maybe some of these true crimes are
donating a part of the proceeds from
every episode to the person impacted in
each episode i don't know what they're
doing over there i'm not going to judge
them maybe there's some that's totally
fair um if they are doing that then i
take back everything that i said
yeah
but i hear what you're saying yeah like
because if they're not doing any of that
it's just weird like
yeah creating a brand off of like other
people's misery no
yeah so that's just my but i don't i
can't speak to it no me neither i've
never listened to youtube but let me
know if they're you know paying it
forward with
with this thing see it's like only
murders in the building like in that
first season did their podcast benefit
the victim
no they like slandered that deli owner
and like the victims like you know
personal
life yeah no seriously like if i
you know i'm tragically ever you know
disappeared or murdered like please
don't make a podcast about me like i
feel like you would like that no because
i wouldn't be like around to get the
followers so like what you should get
the followers no
no not only that but like you know
really personal things come out in an
investigation like obviously they have
to go through your phone like what were
you doing the time like what if at the
time i was like pooping like you know
what i mean like face tuning literally
please like don't make a podcast about
if anything happens to me like i'm not
interested could i do the podcast
okay you know i would i'll aside from
calling you an influencer mentor i
wouldn't say anything slanderous no and
i think like you would i trust your
judgment like if there's something in
the file that like is really
embarrassing to my legacy you would
obviously not
yeah speak it yeah you would just be
like among other things i say it's
classified
that'll be the name of the podcast
clodified claude's declassified
tnn here we come
um so we have a great show five stories
dear toasters which are really unique i
can't wait so i'm ready to dive in
because i'm feeling like we need a
change of pace yes we do so without
further ado
do
you
feel so good to say that when you know
that where are you the choice brothers
are right here it's true on your lap
thrice is on my toe i've got my eyes on
both of them so without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
honey thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best ones it finds to your
cart it supports over 30 000 stores
online ranging from tech and gaming
products to popular fashion brands and
even food delivery so we've been using
honey like if you're not like what are
you doing uh the toasters hooked us to
it literally years ago and now that
they're a sponsor it's just premium
because i get amazing savings and
discounts from honey on makeup
electronics food clothing literally
anything you name it it's so easy it's
free to download when you use our link
then you're shopping check out oh look
press this little gold coin maybe he'll
save you money he'll scour the internet
he'll find a promo code that works for
you boom you're done and now by the way
honey has a safari extension which is
crazy for your phone yeah oh sorry there
is safariana on a computer too um if you
don't already have honey you could
straight up be missing out it is free
and it installs in seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting podcast we would
never recommend something we don't use
so you can get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
toast that's joinhoney.com
toast and today's episode is brought to
you by a personal favorite sponsor of
miss jacqueline dabble for all your
summer travels whether you're going
abroad or staying domestic
and you want to immerse yourself in the
culture now is the perfect time to start
babble babble is a language learning app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions and thanks to babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons there's still time to
learn a new language before you reach
your destination i feel like this is one
of the uh sponsors that everyone's
always like wait you only you only take
it when you need it so everyone's like
what's the babble and so many people are
traveling this summer so listen up if
you want the code and you're ready to
start learning a new language just
because you feel like expanding your
horizons which is always a good thing to
do or you're taking a fabulous summer
trip and you want to you know sing to me
paulo
you only need 10 minutes with babel to
complete a lesson and then you can start
having real life conversations in as
little as three weeks their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective they have 14 different
languages to choose from including
spanish french italiano
and their speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent so you can be like such a local
they won't even know you're just like a
big american tourist start your new
language learning journey today with
babel and right now save up to 60 off
your subscription when you go to
babble.com tmt that's babble b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com slash
t-m-t for up to 60 off your subscription
babble language for life
great thank you so much it's pleasure
our first story brooklyn beckham is
being roasted on social media for
claiming his career as a quote social
media chef paid her for his 1.2 million
dollar car have you seen this no but
like i did see one video where he cooked
so i guess that makes you a chef now so
a viral tick tocker recently caught up
with brooklyn beckham um while he was
out cruising around beverly beverly
hills
red mclaren p1 yes okay the way i
[ __ ] love daniel mac let me tell you
daniel mack is he's a tick tocker
who he started off like so cute and he's
still cute but like his initial content
was so um like innocent he would just
walk around like really nice parts of
different neighborhoods and see really
nice cars and just go up to people and
be like hi i love your car what do you
do for a living yeah people always had
really interesting answers it was never
like wall street like it was always just
something i have a patent it was always
like unique unique things then people
started reaching out to him so he would
get like celebrities on and like go up
to people and it would be like an only
fans model that everyone loves um and he
really like built his brand and then he
bought himself a car and it was like so
cute and i love his videos okay so he
thank you for explaining that that's
what he does he went up to brooklyn
beckham and his mclaren and said by the
way when it's a celebrity like it's
usually staged i don't think this was
really because he said hey man what do
you do for a living your car is awesome
that's what he does it when it's stage
two like with a celebrity he's like been
um in contact with to like get in a
video i think like diplo did one a
million of celebrities have done it okay
well brooklyn beckham responded um i'm a
chef
and then daniel mack was like you're a
chef really are you like the best chef
in the world and he said trying to be
you in brooklyn beckham's defense
what does he do for a living you know no
but then before it comes i do for a
living i was born that's literally what
people are commenting roasting him like
okay maybe you like to cook but that's
not how you paid for your mclaren no for
sure but like if he was put on the spot
which i ha i just i refuse to believe
that this wasn't like a pre-organized
event but if he was put on the spot like
it's a hard question for brooklyn
beckham he doesn't really have a job
right i would have thought he would say
model
yeah i would have said that too i would
say model if i was him obviously wants
to be taken seriously as a chef but like
i really hope this wasn't staged because
that makes him look even worse if it
wasn't stage it's just like an awkward
situation to be in considering like yeah
i didn't i can forgive it if it's not
staged yeah but if he
chose this for himself and really is
that is the tick tock in there
the
like the link to daniel mack
because if it's like so usually he'll go
up to like five different people in a
video and like get their reaction
sometimes people don't want to be on it
sometimes they do but if it's just like
one video dedicated to the person
then it's really like it's a set up
thing you know okay do you want me to
look it up yep
we're gonna get to the bottom of this
and like sometimes he'll like take it
one step further and do yachts it's
really interesting that's a really cool
thing it's a cool comment i wonder that
all the time yeah like what do people do
for a living who have like these big
houses and [ __ ] sometimes they'll get
invited to people's houses
okay a brooklyn beckham here
so mclaren it's a 1.2 million dollar
card that's [ __ ] crazy yeah oh he
knows daniel mack he tagged brooklyn
beckham
are you the best chef in the world let's
see if there's anyone else in the video
because if there isn't my name's
brooklyn yeah we know
any advice for people trying to get into
cooking yeah just follow your passion
whatever makes you happy it's easy to
say when you're like a billion dollars
sounds like someone who doesn't have a
job
he's the only one in the video it's like
a dedicated post i do believe it is um
it looks like it's just like a
coordinated partnership like maybe he
tagged him he wants like maybe tick-tock
followers he probably does want to okay
wait sorry the plot thickens so brooklyn
beckham is like new to tick tock he has
one video
and 48 000 followers his first this
video was posted in 2021 so maybe he's
like getting back into it and the video
he posted in 2021 was of him cooking
um but it does feel
oh his following list is hidden he
follows four people i wonder if he
follows daniel mack he's not letting me
investigate because i guess on tick-tock
you can hide who you follow
wow [ __ ]
i'm starting to feel like this with
stage energy just really
jackie here's helen mirren okay like big
celebrities do it it's kind of like a
press thing now that's cool this video
has 50 million views
that's really cool
i can't believe like her car was 260k i
can't believe he's riding around in a
million lebron james is 770 000. like
why the [ __ ] is brooklyn beckham
no offense someone who's never worked a
day in his life
jealous um
riding around in a car that's worth over
a million dollars and then honestly like
i just feel like if this was strategic
like someone on his team like really
should have advised him against this or
at least helped with the job description
yeah it would have been funny if he if
he like poked fun at himself
yeah
but and i feel like maybe that's not his
car could be his parents could be his
wife
and he just like oh totally he just went
to the coolest car in his arsenal to do
daniel mack not in his arsenal the
coolest car that he had access to right
right to do daniel madden and then
didn't realize that like he sounds kind
of stupid like an out of touch
well i enjoyed talking about it so to
that for that i'm grateful to brooklyn
and nicola and all the people who made
this possible and daniel brooklyn and
nicola are like the top of the news
every single day there's something every
single day because
he um
she was supporting him or he was
supporting her one of them has a project
coming out who knows plus like the
victoria drama right like she's been
speaking on the victoria she dyed her
hair brown did you see that i did i
follow her on instagram and i have to
say it's
it was great during the wedding and
she's just like copying like other
famous people's ins like no i said i do
a q a the other day and like it was like
you know it's meant to be like an
intimate q a as q and a's on instagram
really are sure you learn a lot about
someone and everything was just like
such nonsense like every answer every
answer was like
every question's sort of like what
inspires you sort of thing and like you
know it's just like follow your dreams
like it was [ __ ] nonsense not a drop
of tea and imagine that's nothing she
actually got like how much does your
house cut like she's probably got it how
are things with victoria right right is
brooklyn good in bed like i'm sure she
got no extremely if i was there on time
i would have posted online said she like
probably like chose ones along the lines
of like you know
about her acting career sort of crap
like it was and it's important to
remember that like when like a big time
celebrity or influencer more so
celebrity than influencer but when they
do q and a's they're like extreme
they're doing it for a reason like
i know a lot of people who submit their
own questions and i can't lie i did that
once because i just wanted to clear
something up but like they do it to
either like to portray an image or to
address one particular thing so like
it's clear that her q a was not really
like get to know me and like what my
life is like it's like yes i'm an
actress take me seriously i'm an artist
yeah no it was a bunch of nonsense huey
and i wanted to see if she like saved it
to her highlight so i could give you an
example of the nonsensicalness it was
brooklyn it was nicholas mindless q a
you know and you know what like it kind
of makes sense like why they're
compatible because like they're both
like extremely privileged they're both
kind of out of touch they're living in
the clouds they're living in the clouds
like on another planet that i would love
to inhabit it must be so nice to just
bring them no to nothing anything no to
not know what it's like to record a
podcast and realize that your sister's
microphone is off
and she posted like a long thing on her
instagram the other day about like
anxiety emotions yeah
um
i think to tell us that like
everything's not what it seems and that
she has bad days too i'm sure she does
but again but they're not worse than
mine his couch in like nonsensical
language you know it's like this
celebrity language full of like buzz
words and empty words i just want to
give an example because i want you guys
to just like understand yeah i think i
know what you're talking about but
please an example would be great
yeah the picture is of her cry like
looking very sad
gorgeous so right and that's what i look
like when i cry i don't know if you guys
know that young stunning sometimes i
find it hard to show the sad bits of me
growing up with seven siblings and two
very strong parents made me really tough
they hammered it into me not to let
people bring me down or hurt my heart it
made me put up such a wall to protect
myself and especially in this industry
actually as i'm reading this out loud i
feel like this is her way of responding
to bella to the criticism that she's a
mean girl like i put up walls to protect
myself because of like the way i grew up
can i tell you that when i read it for
the first time like on my instagram feed
it felt i i literally felt like it was a
direct response to like the bella thorne
accusation all those years ago this
accusation that she's an ice queen that
like her and victoria are in this cold
war because they're both really icy so i
feel like that's what she's saying
perhaps
we all have days where people make you
feel bad and it's okay to be hurt by it
like that's just like nonsense but okay
no end like
that's just like wait say it again look
i all have days where make where people
make you feel bad and it's okay to be
hurt by it
no we know that like we learned that in
school like it's called processing
emotions like that's a celebrity thing
saying the most obvious thing in a fancy
way and acting like it's a revelation
yeah you guys wait i just learned it's
okay to be sad and and you could be sad
too sometimes and then they'll make it
like a trendy like it's okay to not be
okay
right so it's giving nonsensicalness
yeah this part i just thought i would
write something because i never showed
this side of me here i wanted to show
you this side of me
i'm still unsure which side this side
that like could get hurt
oh my god she's
she's human holy [ __ ] i didn't know that
that's what she's saying i think and i i
don't want to like laugh at someone
saying no i actually really like her and
i support her i just like
cut back the nonsense everyone please
yeah like just show us who you are or
don't be on social media honestly it's
like
when people only show like the highlight
reel and then
are like well there's this part of me
too and it's like well you're the one
who only showed us the good part right
if we think a certain way it's because
you told us to think that way right
totally
that's why
that's how i feel about like erica jane
and tom
she's always like it was so dark i'm
like you made him seem like it wasn't
yes the king it's confusing for sure i
read your book i had so much respect for
him and they're telling me the whole
time it was terrible right and it's
possible that like you're covering up
but like to go so far on one extreme
would glow about him so true it was
unnecessary right no one asked
nobody erica thomas just the best right
yeah um but
i can't wait to try some of his food
brooklyn yeah he better be a good chef
after all this after all of this yeah
they did like one video on like vogue
when they were engaged like
cooking with the pelts beckhams
yeah that always like feels like a weird
thing like celebrities who
just want to try something new chef yeah
no and i think it's like definitely
insulting to the chef community like oh
yeah
i put myself through culinary school
busing tables like i worked so hard my
whole life taking [ __ ] job after [ __ ]
job education education this opportunity
to finally make it and to call myself a
chef yeah and you made it possible in
his and you're a chef
yeah well by that standard i'm
definitely a chef because i make cereal
all the time and you make dinner for
theo so true and that's not easy
especially recently it sounds too
antibiotic it's been really tough a lot
of mixing you're also a chemist
my cauldron
spooky are you ready for our next story
that what claudia sent to me she put it
in she said she wanted in the stories
yeah and that's what you get when you
follow
i'm like embarrassed like because i'm
literally forgetting her name and she's
like actually my friend
what is alice's name ashley green i'm so
sorry
when you follow when you follow ashley
green she's the host of the twilight
effect podcast which i was on one time
check it out um and they always have
like interesting guests and this time
they had i think the director um he was
just sharing information
here's what he shared taylor swift was
turned down for a part in twilight new
moon because it would have been too
distracting
i'm having like heartburn no
like the lights in my head it's just
like i'm feeling like light-headed do
you want me to read
i don't know what what's wrong with me
maybe i'm just like looking in too many
places have you had something to eat
today sweetheart yeah i had oatmeal and
a go macro bar so i should be full all
right let me know if you want to do the
reading i'm such a good reader i think
it's just like maybe i have a just kind
of a dull headache at all times and it's
brightening and it's really bright yeah
taylor swift was apparently rejected
from a role as an extra and twilight new
moon as the director thought her
appearance would steal focus from the
rest of the film at the time of the
twilight saga's prominence the singer
was a known fan of the books and films
she was a try hard in a new interview
chris white's who directed the second
twilight film revealed that he
reluctantly had to deny her the part of
an extra in the background taylor was a
huge dot tryhard and taylor and i had
the same asian at the time and he said
taylor would like to be in this movie
not because of you but because she's a
twihard she would be someone at the
cafeteria or the diner or whatever but
she just wants to be in this movie
although it wouldn't have been a major
role for the singer the director
believed that the surprise appearance of
a major celebrity would distract from
the rest of the film as a result he
turned on the proposition he said the
hardest thing for me was to be like the
moment that taylor swift walks onto the
screen for about five minutes nobody's
going to be able to process anything i
kicked myself for it too because i was
like wow i could have been hanging out
with taylor swift um i just want to say
i think he's wrong wow okay and the
reason why i think that is because of
what game of thrones did having aaron
rodgers and chris stapleton in like the
final season because they were huge fans
took away from nothing just a fun little
fact she could have easily been
disguised and by the way like twilight
is as big of a machine as taylor swift
was at the at at that time now she's
like you know that would be like having
beyonce in your movies but at that time
she was still huge but it just would
have been like a really fun thing yeah
and i don't think it would have
distracted at all and if anything like
new moon would have been distracting
because it was bad yeah the thing about
new moon is that it's vitally safe
because edward is in it for 45 seconds
and eclipse is actually the worst one
because that's the one about newborns no
for sure but like edward's in it being
sexy and like you know the end is like
bad like
the plot is not my favorite but like
there's goodness in it [ __ ] second
one edward's gone bella is [ __ ]
depressed like it sucks yeah and she
said there's a possibility
that's a song playing when she's going
around
there's a possibility
she's like it's snowing
then there's leaves
it's blossoming they're changing seasons
are changing and she's just like
depressed like not leaving her house
because edward's [ __ ] gone and i
would do the same [ __ ] thing that
reminds me of the special i'm grateful
for the seasons yeah from tim dylan you
love quoting comedy special i do i
wonder what that says about me um that
you're hilarious that's what it says i
think so i'm able to apply comedy jargon
in everyday life everyday life i was
gonna say that i obviously think that
like while it would have been amazing it
definitely would have been a distraction
but you do raise an interesting point
about game of thrones even though i
don't think that chris stapleton or
aaron rodgers are as visually as
distracting even together
as
also because i mean i guess like they
were playing like cavemen and they look
like cavemen whereas like she would be
playing a high school senior and she
does look like a high school senior so
she could fit in but like taylor's just
she's not one to blend in you know yeah
also like in high school musical
too at the end like miley gets a cameo
and like that just added to the movie it
was a fun thing she's dancing like
great and she was like a huge star at
the time yeah that's no that's totally
true and by the way what's interesting
is what they did do in and it's not like
it was the first twilight where it's
like this could eclipse the whole
franchise it's like taylor's in the
movie they had some good really i mean
good momentum huge momentum it was the
biggest franchise in the world like
throw her in yeah especially because i
think in the fourth movie breaking down
part one the woman who wrote the book
stephanie meyer is an extra she's a
guest at the wedding so you see her in
the ceremony when bella's walking down
and then i think you see her like eating
a piece of cake um
and a lot the fandom knew her very well
so
there is a way to do it in a way that's
like not distracting and classy but i'm
also curious about the timing um as it
pertains to taylor lautner
oh was she trying to just
be with her man or they were together
during that movie valentine's day and
that was so much later right but so like
maybe she was like into him
and like that was like her first and it
didn't work out so she like forgot about
it but then later on they happened to be
cast in a movie together wow maybe she
was like had a crush on him for many
years and of all the men taylor has
stated i don't think anyone you know has
more glowing review than taylor lautner
back to december it's like the only song
where like she's wrong you know yeah and
she goes back to december all the time
beautiful turns out freedom ain't
nothing but missing you wishing i didn't
realize what i had when you were mine
i go back to december turn around and
change my own mind she's mad at herself
she like literally like bounced and he
was just like this is such a nice guy
you know yeah but now i'm happy for him
because he's engaged to a girl named
taylor so we all win we really do
especially
taylor
who gets to marry taylor honor right
we're all winners are you ready for our
next story
julia louis-dreyfus son charlie has
joined the sex lives of college girls
cast
wait
julia louis dreyfus's youngest son named
charlie has been cast in season two of
sex lives with college girls that show
which i adore is literally breeding
ground for nepotism timothy my sister
everyone you know so true
uh
but he really looks like a regular
college guy and he's an actor and he's
in other projects too but it looks like
a perfect casting now i don't know this
man i'm sorry to this man um but when it
comes to nepotism i very much judge on a
case-by-case basis and i will not be
judging in a negative way because julia
louis dreyfus you know has contributed
so much
to
pop culture to television to
entertainment she could do whatever the
[ __ ] she wants and honestly her son's
kind of hot so yeah
what how old to say he's 26 25. i don't
want to be out here calling like 14 year
olds hot you know kids these days
they're like 12 and they look 25. yeah
when they're also 25 and they're like
12. it's so confusing and yet i'm 28 and
look 24. how old do you guys think we
are sound off in the comments actually
sure jackie i'm not interested in
hearing what anyone thinks about how i
look honestly wow yeah what if it's a
compliment
no because it might be a compliment
they think but really
it's an influencer mentor yeah because
people are always like oh my god and
it's so nice like ever since i've like
lost like 25 pounds actually um people
are like you look amazing like
sorry and it looked amazing before okay
i just want you to know if you go back
to before you started dieting and you
look at pictures from like the show post
show pictures like every day people are
like okay your skin's going your hair is
amazing where's your ombre from
okay
okay no that's fair yeah it's just
interesting but like you know it's not
like you're only getting compliments if
that's life you know like somebody says
something and you internalize it in a
different language right but also you do
look good like leave it at that take the
compliment take the win walk away no for
sure for sure
being gorgeous it's it's a lot of mental
you know
yeah anguish um do the flip
you have to stop quoting a special
nobody knows what we're talking about
okay i'm quoting for tim dillon special
go watch it do a flip
i
love sex lives of college girls i think
it's so good waiting for season two with
baited breath
excited about julia let me drive fast me
too i i hope that he's great i mean
timothy charlie's sister is great so
sometimes nepotism can open you up to a
great talent hundred percent i'm open to
it
and timothy chalamet's sister is the
best part of the show she's so [ __ ]
funny and i love renee rapp i've been
like
keeping up with her post show but her
brother isn't on season two like i know
her brother on the show yeah that guy
who was [ __ ] kimberly yeah which was
just like a a
nico i know he got like another job that
show's gonna be like the next girls like
i don't know why anyone would leave it
[ __ ] people are so dumb it like
it's fun to watch it
but it could never be me like i get on a
hit show you have to drag me off the set
my cold dead body you'll be doing like
the reboot you'll be doing the re-watch
podcast i'm the first one to sign up i'm
doing it all yeah
are you ready for our next story like
really special i'm lucas graybiel
for sure
sorry you were the first one in the
reboot yeah first one to sign up the
first one posting on social media it's
in my bio like no you know who you are
who
bart johnson
you're on cameo 100
i'm bart johnson
because i'm still really good-looking um
even after the show's long over and i
will be the first one um on set you're
commenting on all these the reboot
happens you're commenting on all the
cast members i'm commenting news is post
every time they post about something
even remotely disney related you are
doing cameos in character i'm
[ __ ] bart johnson what are you
two doing in a tree
evil [ __ ] laugh
okay
are you ready for our next story
tamara judge is closing cut fitness
after nearly 10 years in business quote
it's sad that is sad camera and her
husband eddie are saying goodbye to
their business people can confirm that
the couple have officially closed cut
fitness the gym they own in rancho santa
margherita california the pair opened
the studio in march 2013. unlike big box
chain gyms the fitness studio focused on
personal training
uh nutrition coaching and spartan race
chaining among other things sounds
horrible don't know if you know this but
cut stands for cardio unique training
and i just it's getting sir no but
that's your favorite word it's unique
yeah no this definitely feels like a
rip-off of sir like no but they had a
10-year run uh she talked about it on
her podcast with telly teddy mellencamp
which we haven't discussed the fact that
they have a podcast together i know and
i feel like i'm always seeing it around
the church and stuff i feel like it does
pretty well i love that for them like
it's surprising that they're friends
yeah but you know what it's the recipe
for perfection like two house two fired
housewives who will literally do
anything to stay relevant on their
respective shows um
it's literally like you can't create
more chaos than that like they're both
clinging on to
what they once had but i feel like
that's
even if other housewives like tried to
do this it would just be sad but there's
something like pretty respectable about
their podcast i don't know why i feel
that way but i think because they
actually do it they do it and it's
always charting sometimes they make news
it's called two t's in a pod a really
cute name
and i guess because they're like an
unexpected duo anyways they're making
news once again uh but
tamara is sad about the gym i think it's
really the end of an era but she also
talked about her cbd company you know
they have a cbd they were on our podcast
talking about it being a cbd they're
sold at sally beauty stores and tamara
said um we their cbd success business is
very successful it pays her way more
than the show
so i thought that was interesting that
is interesting and you know what like
having a
brick and mortar store for 10 years is
not easy no matter what you're selling
no and to own a gym in
covid was really hard so to have made it
this far is an accomplishment it's an
accomplishment um it is the end of an
era you know it's like koto insurance
it's iconic um
but
you know when she came on our show to
talk about her cbd like they pitched her
for the cbd and we're like yeah sure but
we just wanted to talk to tamara and
then the more i spoke to her about it
the vibe i got was like she was running
like an actual like legitimate business
and i think she must have like invested
a lot of money in this like really early
on and it's paying off i do believe that
her cbd company is like legit yeah i
mean to me and sally beauty is not easy
yeah so good for her yeah and have to
assume she was making about a million
dollars a season um on housewives so
that means
she's making more than a million dollars
yeah i thought that was you know a
little bittersweet news yeah no it's sad
but it's time yeah but also maybe it's
like it was time to move on from the gym
because these other ventures are just
more profitable or it was time to move
on from the gym because she didn't have
the show to really supplement like
marketing wise like yeah no one would
have heard of cut fitness it just would
have been like another nice gym in
orange county but like being attached to
the show and having all the events there
and all the girls going to train there
like it's good marketing right but she
is going back on the show so i feel like
she could have held out if she wanted to
yeah but maybe just wasn't worth it yeah
that's what i'm saying so i hope
everything's okay speaking of another
institution that's shutting down but
some good news so i don't know if we
spoke about this or if you guys knew
that the central park boathouse is
closing oh
you knew that i told you i'm gonna
remember which really is like iconically
sad iconically sad yeah the new york
post had written like an op-ed about why
we need to save the boathouse and the
secret billionaire has made a six
million dollar offer to save the central
park boathouse after reading the post i
wish a secret billionaire would just
like save me
um
but that is so cute gotta know who he is
just because like the more billionaires
i'm aware of the better
um but i love that you know it's
important to invest in your city
and i'm glad someone else is so i don't
have to
and i've never been to the boathouse so
i know it's iconic it's where carrie and
big fell into the lake like i know all
about it i've just personally never been
there so
yeah so the operator had said he had no
choice but to close the central park
restaurant on october 17th due to
skyrocketing costs then the secret
billionaire approached the operator with
a deal to finance the renovation of the
iconic property and keep it open under
his current contract with the city
the original author of the new york post
op-ed said however you played it this is
bad news for the city a darkened
boathouse would leave a heartbreaking
hole in the park at a time when new
york's green lung needs all the
wholesome law-abiding human trafficking
it can handle it's so true like this is
like if it were to officially close it
would just be like reflective of the
state of the city like you know exiting
the pandemic just not doing well um so
you know what
alas there is hope yeah so i think
that's some some good positive news if
you were hoping to get married at the
boathouse one day like the jury is still
alive recreating the carrion big kiss
thing yeah um also if anyone happens to
know like who the secret billionaire is
like i'm just like curious and nosy so
write in the comments or if you like
don't want to like out yourself feel
free to send me a dm i'm just like
beyond curious like there's so many
billionaires why must it be a secret i
feel like owning the boathouse would be
you know a crown jewel in your portfolio
so it's probably like a billionaire
who's not famous and like doesn't want
to be famous he likes being rich like he
knows maybe he looks out on the park and
wants to see it flourishing no he's
probably smart enough and like
experienced enough to know like people
want to be rich and famous and really if
they were rich it would solve 99 of
their problems like fame does nothing
yeah but there's so much ego
yeah but so i'm saying like a normal
billionaire might not do it but we
happen to find like a humble billionaire
something great husband we're disgusting
saying hey
let's be real it's probably my god it's
probably
um
unless it's mackenzie you know i mean
that is so terrible of me but like i
mean it's kylie
can you and let me just google something
really quick like how many features
billionaires maybe it's female
billionaires
percentage male billionaires i never
know like what to say into google like i
just typed the whole thought how many
female billionaires are there compared
to thank you as of 2022 number of
billionaires around the world in 2019 by
gender okay so statistics are on my side
i'm not just being a [ __ ]
but this is also in the world male
2 489 billionaires yeah female 336 so
it's like it's apples into oranges um
and that's not to say women can't be
billionaires i just know the world we
live in so i'm not saying i don't
believe women can be
she never said that i was sitting here
the whole time i've never said that i
know statistics because you know i'm
always watching those videos like now
this you know that like weird like that
was like putting [ __ ] together and it's
like always sharing random [ __ ] it's
like here's the you know the richest
person in every state
and
this is just the statistics not me
there's like two women and they're
either like an heiress or a widow yeah
or a divorcee right so
sorry i'm not just like being a [ __ ]
against women it's just what the thing
is facts are
and that's because women aren't given
opportunities and that's not my fault
don't [ __ ] put that on me you [ __ ]
[ __ ] she's creating opportunities for
women all the time 100
to have a great i'm creating
opportunities for women to have a great
time at my show tickets available at
girl no job.com tour so i can be the
397th
female billionaire and you know what i
would do
keep it all for myself
and for theo of course and of course
give to children he could get his foot
fixed because i'll give it to charity
the charity world is everything no my
charity is um
cookies for claudia turpin family
thank you for bringing it back you get a
big house oh no actually that might be
you know i was actually thinking when
diane was telling us all about this mike
diane buy them a house like seriously
like just pay the mortgage for the rest
of your life like come on you have so
much money like i know it's not on her
but i can't imagine she wasn't so moved
by everything she learned and like i'm
sure they sat down for the interview
ready just like to see how life was
going and wasn't expecting to find that
like it's still going on and i'm just
like come on diane or justin bieber too
like come on
agreed and i think that you know when
you're watching yes
and maybe she does gift but i think also
part of her
her
job
like she probably has to draw a line
somewhere because if she was moved by
every single
case she should own like 11 homes she
would have yeah so
that's just not sustainable yeah but it
was just like
dan was like oh no what can we do i'm
like i don't know are you like the most
powerful woman in the world like right
do something
right you're chasing down this like
moronic chairwoman of the council of
this local board it's like diane
sawyer's here like
diane like make a call we're saved make
a call
start another fun put on your instagram
call your friends yeah
i just thought it was like
oh no i'm like diane like that's like
when a lot of celebrities get backlash
for posting like gofundmes for their
family members or their friends and the
friends family and it's like well you
could pay the bills yes i do think that
it depends on the celebrity because
there's this general like
i think a lot of people overestimate the
type of money certain celebrities make
but like lady gaga posting like save my
dad's restaurant like you [ __ ] save
your dad's restaurant [ __ ] i just
bought your album like go [ __ ] do it
that was weird of her like low-key yeah
not cool
not cool
are you ready for your toasters
yes
dear toasters is brought to you by noom
when anyone decides to lose weight it's
not usually just about the number on the
scale i know for money i can tell you
that it's i it really doesn't even
matter for me it's like about overall
well-being i know it's about like
fatigue there's so many things that come
when i'm just not being healthy
um
and that's why nume is a really
interesting approach if you're looking
to make a change nume wait is ready to
help nume wait's psychology-based
approach empowers you with the knowledge
and support to build lasting results
with their psychology first approach
they
are helping more than 3.6 million people
lose weight every journey is different
so your daily lessons are personalized
and
personalized to you and your goals the
program is based on scientific
principles like cognitive behavioral
therapy to help you understand your
relationship with food so i know a lot
of people find a lot of different
beneficial things from noom i know we
both have
talked about how what we really like
about it is just like they have a food
database and it's just so interesting
like when you're eating stuff like if
you're not really thinking about it
you're not thinking about what's in the
food um so they have a really extensive
database that just lets you know like
what exactly is in everything you're
eating um and you can track your day see
your dad's plans at a glance which i
think is really helpful yeah i'll catch
you in three weeks when i'm weaned off
of breastfeeding we're getting back to
work me and newm and you can stay
focused on what's important to you with
noon weights psychology-based approach
sign up for your trial today at noom.com
toast that's
o o m
dot com slash toast to sign up for your
trial today
excuse me what do you have to lose sorry
it wasn't in the copy actually i think
maybe they've moved on from that
sentiment um dear toasters our wednesday
weekly advice segment so if you're
looking for advice from your two
favorite gal pals um you can email
deartoasters gmail.com deartosters
gmail.com and we'll keep it anonymous
you can change people's names we'll
never know and if you write us an email
and then you regret it and you follow up
like please don't read this we do get
those emails too so don't worry we're
never gonna read something nobody wants
us to read we have three really good
ones today okay
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go like
least crazy to most crazy okay good i
need to work my way up i need to turn
these lights off so i can think okay
ready
hello beautiful stunning and smart
queens
i'm a long time male toaster brother
breather grunge instagram follower
comedy tour guest who is this man
i've recently come across some news
regarding one of my close friends that i
just cannot shake from my head my friend
let's call her margot has recently
shared with me that she only showers
once a week
this came up when we were at a fair and
i said to her that i was gonna go home
and shower for the second time that day
after walking around the heat and the
fog of the barbecue smoke for hours she
then shared with me that she only
showers on sundays mind you it was
friday she tried to explain to me that
her lack of bathing is the reason for
her skin being so soft and that the
reason she hates showering is due to
some unresolved trauma from her
childhood apparently her parents would
make her shower every day and she
absolutely hated it and it would cause
conflict in her family this then created
some resentment from her towards
showering i've heard you both talk about
this on the podcast before so i just
wanted some input input on how to
navigate this she doesn't ever really
smell and i'm not sleeping with her yet
but i just can't shake this every time i
see slash think of her please give me
your thoughts slash advice is sincerely
a clean toaster who usually showers
twice a day but at least once okay so
two things first the fact that she
showers uh once a week and then i'll get
into like the reason the trauma the
trauma
but the first thing
showering once we get not most of us do
it but if you're saying she doesn't
smell she has this like gorgeous skin
and maybe she's on to something okay so
she'll smell like barbecue for the next
two days but if you're not gonna be with
her and it really doesn't bother you
that's just like a weird thing i would
also just double check that she didn't
mean she washes her hair once a week
because there's two different types of
showers um and girls like i have like
three different types of showers you
know like one full immersion going in
hair everything shaving
second is like a light body between
washes you know and then the second is
like a the third it's like a deep body
no hair
like everyone has their own i just
really have two i have three showering
without hair showering with hair but
there i think there's two different
types of showering without hair okay but
say she's talking about like she really
doesn't shower shower i mean back in the
day people only took baths whenever they
could carry all the water no i'm sorry
taking a shower once a week is not
normal so
we have to get to the root of it and it
sounds like we're at the root of it i do
feel like she's probably holding back on
she wasn't gonna share like her deepest
childhood trauma like all the details at
the barbecue i feel like there's
probably more there
yeah i would assume there is because
just being forced to shower every day
that's like what parents make you take a
shower that's a growing up so i feel
like there's more probably unresolved
trauma there and i honestly would take
the route of encouraging her to explore
that with a therapist yeah that's what i
was going to say that's being a good
friend honestly like yeah you can't help
her yeah just be like i thought about
what you said and it's really stuck with
me
um and i want i care about you yeah and
i just like want to see you thriving i
don't want you to be like held back and
not like showering because of something
from your childhood like have you ever
thought of talking to someone yeah i
haven't heard the soft skin thing um so
as far as i know that's not true
no showering dries out your skin
so moisturize it afterwards but like if
you don't i mean how can water dehydrate
your skin oh
because it takes away from the oils
because water and oil don't mix
oh okay whatever bill nye
um so what was our advice talk to her
about it encourage her to
recommend help yeah like dig into that
yeah something that should be resolved
yeah even if she just she gets to the
bottom of the trauma but still only
wants to shower once a week because she
likes how it makes her skin feel that's
fine for her right she'll be clean on
the inside
all right next up
good morning ladies first of all thank
you for always delivering premium
content no matter what obviously this
was written before yesterday
i'm in a giant pickle for some backstory
i had a boyfriend in high school who was
my first everything his name was jack
and we really loved each other but we
had some different goals and plans at
that point in our lives we've talked
maybe three to four times in the last 11
years never wanting to commit to never
wanting to commit otherwise he lived all
over the country and really focused on
building his career he was engaged at
one point but called it off fast forward
to this weekend i woke up at 6 a.m on
sunday to go to the gym and i had a
venmo notification on my phone it was
for one dollar and it was from jack
it had his phone number in the comment
part of the notification i've recently
been thinking about him and he reached i
had recently been thinking about him and
he reaches out like this the
notification came in around 5 a.m so he
obviously had been up drinking all night
i don't know if that's a fair he was up
thinking about you he couldn't sleep he
also was going to the
yeah
i had to work after the gym so i waited
to call him i called in the afternoon
and we talked for almost two hours just
catching up as if no time has passed
which was how this worked with him every
time we caught up when i told him that i
was engaged he seemed genuinely happy
for me he's not on socials at all so he
had no way of knowing that in this
conversation he told me the other
efforts he had made in the recent past
to get a hold of me i'm obviously very
in love with my fiance and i want to
spend the rest of my life with him but
jack has always been in the back of my
mind am i making a mistake to not see
him next time he's in town end of
october or do i block his number and not
even entertain it i struggle with living
the rest of my life with a what if in
the back of my mind please help i will
take the dragging through the mud if
that's what's warranted love a forever
loyal toaster oh my god this is like a
movie i was gonna say it sounds like a
book i mean i would have to really know
what your fiance is like
but like is there a world in which you
could be like i need to have a
conversation with someone like before we
move forward
are you open to that
like if you seemed like a really jealous
type or like a protective type like you
would know immediately that that's not
something he would be open to but it
reminds me of this book i read once you
love za
you know her new fiance really
understood she was like you need to
spend time with your ex-husband like
make sure that like i don't want to be
like your runner up like i want you to
choose me because you want to choose me
yeah that's very
that's your fantasy yeah what i would
say to you is you know he could always
be the one that got away but i do think
we have a tendency to romanticize the
past and i think you had like a high
school relationship
um he probably seems really good and you
know every time you talk for two hours
it's you know you have like a cute
probably a little flirty conversation
and it's like fun and exciting but to
live life with someone every single day
and to find a person who you enjoy doing
that with um
it's not the same it's a huge feat and
maybe every day in and out of jack it's
not going to be those two hour
conversations and i think you know the
bird in the hand is worth two in the
bush in this case and it's not like you
were having doubts about your fiance
before right and i think like jack in
theory is like oh so exciting in
practice you know it's another tough
relationship that you got to work
through and i just don't think that i
think you know
it's like cute and fun and sweet right
now
but
you have the real thing
with your fiance right now and there's
no way to know if you would have that
with jack just because every few years
you talk for two hours and reminisce
about the good old days we were just
talking about this on the podcast about
how like
a lot of people look back and like
romanticize that like last year of high
school the summer before college like
and in actuality like it wasn't really
like that for anyone we just like look
back on that time now through like
rose-colored lenses whether it's because
of like movies we've watched or just
like our youth and nostalgia so you're
probably right in the sense that like
you're remembering him better or more
romantically than it was not even that
it's like so say you meet someone who
you enjoy for like an afternoon and then
you start thinking like oh my gosh like
every day would be like that if you know
we were together but it's like
no think about the first time you met
your fiance like right but the fact that
you do have a life that you love with
your fiance like it really doesn't get
better than that 100 percent adds that
it's going to be better with jack
considering it's pretty good right now
are extremely slim and considering like
you really don't know him anymore like a
couple phone calls over 11 years is not
a friendship mate yeah no that's not a
relationship that's not living with
someone like i think you found it yeah
i'm with jax and i think that if you
actually went down the road of exploring
things with jack it would not work out
just because most relationships don't
work out hashtag i'm with her she's
right listen to jackie don't say
anything i say no i think you were
agreeing with me no for sure but like
your phrasing was just more on point all
right this is the one i really wanted to
get to okay oh gosh because honestly i
don't have any expertise in this at all
do i i don't think so but again i've
never looked up your butthole so oh hey
jackson clone hey i've been dating this
new guy for a few months
and i have yet to tell him about a
personal issue i have
hemorrhoids
i try my best to not let them be seen
during sex and i don't think he has ever
seen them if he has he's just being nice
and not mentioning it so my dilemma is
that i have to have a procedure done
next week where i have to be put under
it's basically a colonoscopy and i don't
know if i should tell him about it or
not i've never been put to sleep before
so i'm nervous but i'm just too
embarrassed to tell him do you think i
should just get this procedure done and
keep it a secret or should i go ahead
and tell him so i don't have to keep
hiding it while i simultaneously work on
incorporating more fiber into my diet to
shrink the voids
if so how should i go about telling him
a toaster in distress how long have they
been together a few months
i think that you should tell him now
there's something about the word
hemorrhoids that's like i don't know
maybe it was in a movie or something
where it's like you know it's like a
gross word yeah so
when that when actual hemorrhoids are
just like actually extremely common
occurrence for many people yeah so if
you want to go full hemorrhoid go for it
i always think honesty is the best
policy if you're having a major surgery
and you are seeing someone like you have
to tell him you're doing something you
could like lie and say that it's
something like gynecological and then he
won't ask any more questions
or you could just be
honest um
yeah i'm okay with like a lie by
omission like yeah i'm getting the thing
done down come pick me up like but i
think like you don't really have to go
into like 100 detail like first of all
you'll learn a lot when he's
when you're out of surgery like he's the
one taking care of you if he is like
that's what husbands do so you'll really
be able to see and you know if it's
going really well maybe you can just be
like
okay like i was a little embarrassed
like honestly you've been so great i
actually just have hemorrhoids like no
big deal but if you got through it he
didn't know
like and no but then like what if he's
like acting like a child and you're like
oh wow i'm so [ __ ] glad i didn't tell
this guy if hemorrhoids he's obviously
like so immature and not husband
material you know right i think we
should see how he acts like a good test
yeah it really is because that's what
happens like when you're married like
your husband sees you at your [ __ ]
worst norovirus like
you birth oh
well i haven't been there yet but yeah
like you're like like
flesh everything like yeah so if he's
gonna be a [ __ ] [ __ ] about some
procedure like
he's actually doing you a favor and
saving you a lot of time but if he's
great it's a good test i would use it as
a test yeah
i would tell him of some version of the
truth
um
and if it's going really well
i think he'll think i don't think he'll
find it like deceptive of you i think
he'll find it like cute of you like
that you didn't want to like there's
nothing deceptive and it's not like it's
a big thing like it's it's not like
something that's like contagious like
you have memories yeah it's so common
it's like uh when you zoom out from the
lens of the big bang theory you
literally can't even see them that's i
mean it depends how big the hemorrhoids
are
um that was your toaster thank you to
everyone for being particularly
vulnerable this week dear toasters at
gmail.com for next wednesday's show that
is our episodes this is a very long
episode and i'm glad because after
yesterday's audio everyone deserves it
so fingers crossed that when we take
this sd card out of no it works fine
we're fine you never know um so that's
our show
our show no one else's even though the
stripes brothers are here it's not their
show it's our show we have a great day
ahead of us we're headed to our
spritz meet and greet in fort lauderdale
so we're excited to see everyone there
tonight and we're back tomorrow with
another fabulous show um
i think that's it thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
monday morning show where we deliver the
past five stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you are watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so it's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio ir radio cast box
all the places so whenever you listen to
podcasts find us morning tell us leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have any crab hump day
i'm
you need babble to figure that out 100
and we'll see you tomorrow goodbye